sie freuen sich völlig zu recht noch
genau eine woche und wir sind alle
gerettet nächsten freitag stellt die
groko ihr konzept zum klimaschutz vor
sie haben richtig gehört ein
regelrechtes konzept und zeit wird's ja
denn bis jetzt hat sich da noch nicht so
viel getan in dieser angelegenheit man
nennt angela merkel schon die ritter
nichtstun berg von berlin
aber ja es ist ja wirklich keine linie
erkennbar
die spd will irgendeine art von co2
abgabe was immer das sein mag die union
will emissionshandel der aber in europa
gar nicht funktioniert und der staunende
bürgerkrieg von morgens bis abends neue
klima ideen um die ohren gefächert
was ist denn eigentlich aus erst denken
dann reden geworden ideen für den schutz
des klimas gibt es in deutschland in
diesen tagen ja viele plastiktüten
einfach verbieten band waren günstiger
machen 365 euro ticket anti dumping
steuern hier ist zum beispiel auch die
klimasteuer reformen
und er
vor
gehört doch jetzt auf in england können
wir den nicht nehmen ich fasse das
gehörte konzept noch mal für sie
zusammen auf inlandsflügen sind
ölheizungen verboten es sei denn man
kauft für 365 euro im jahr eine
plastiktüte oder so ähnlich mein gott
diese kakophonie aus berlin ist ein
verheerendes signal ganz im ernst so
merkt auch der letzte dass es noch gar
keinen plan zum klima gibt ja manchmal
denke ich wirklich die frau merkel ist
schon mit anderthalb beinen in der
frührente aber mindestens freunde
mindestens sie hat doch das pariser
klimaabkommen mit unterschrieben
oder hat sie es vorher nicht gelesen die
redet oft als hätte sie mit dem ganzen
quatsch gar nichts zu tun
zum beispiel mit dem immer noch viel zu
hohen co2 ausstoß im deutschen verkehr
denn wir müssen 40 bis 2030 bezogen auf
1990 einsparen
und wir haben bis heute von 1990 an
nichts eingespart nichts gemacht
ich bin regelrecht enttäuscht von mir
selbst bei der mutter seit 14 jahren im
amt
wer hat sie denn daran gehindert eine
echte verkehrswende einzuleiten ich
nicht
ihre dritte groko überlegen sie mal
ihren dritten gruppe arbeitet auch schon
seit zwei jahren und jetzt haben sie
gemerkt verdammt in einer woche ist
abgabe für das klimakonzept ja immer auf
den allerletzten drücker ja erinnert
mich an mich selbst als mir damals im
mai 1985 plötzlich sieben teils
eingefallen ist dass ich am nächsten tag
abi prüfung habe
scheiße wo ist ihr hobby
[Musik]
mama
auf den letzten drücker
immer auf den letzten drücker seht ihr
kinder und deswegen muss ich heute beim
zdf arbeit nächsten samstag da ist nicht
mehr viel zeit fliegt die kanzlerin zum
großen uno klimagipfel nach new york da
muss sie irgendwas vorweisen
das wird super wenn sie da am rednerpult
ihren koffer aufmachen und dann ist da
grüne bananen drin und her bierdeckel
auf denen sie im flieger noch schnell
ihre ideen gekritzelt hat alles hin
gehandelt
genau wie der neue haushalt für 2020
da sind die kosten für den klimaschutz
überhaupt noch nicht mit drin kann man
nicht erst mal wirklich schlüssiges
klima konzept erarbeiten lebe lieber
nicht perfekter schritt in die konkrete
richtung also auf der suche nach der
perfekten lösung am ende gar nichts zu
machen also second best ist allemal
besser als nachsicht ja lieber second
best als massing absolut wenn ich
darüber nachdenke den spruch sollten wir
wirklich oben an den rechtsstaat
schreiben lieber säcken blecht als
nothing ja
ja das passt zur politik insgesamt klar
klar sie wollen uns wähler merken sie
nicht mit den konkreten
klimaschutzkosten verschrecken weil sie
immer nur von wahl zu wahl denken allein
um genügend wohnraum auf null emissionen
zu dämmen allein dafür müssten wir in
deutschland jedes jahr 14 milliarden
investiert nur dafür aber kommen das
macht nur unnötig schlechte laune
dann lieber gut gelaunt ablenken herr
cars ist das wirklich ein ehrlicher
haushalt klima ist noch nicht drin und
die grundrente auch nicht neu nächste
frage ja hauptsache wir halten unsere
blöde schwarze null der rest ergibt sich
diese woche gab es schon wieder einen
anschiss vom iwf weil deutschland zu
wenig geld investiert sagen alle
experten dabei sind klimaschutz und
energiewende echte jahrhundertaufgabe
da muss man endlich ja ich weiss nicht
groß denken da sind visionäre
erfindungen gefragt das ist das hier das
ist hergestellt aus dem meeres müll das
ist ja hier so dann hat man einfach
einen beutel dabei man kann ihnen ganz
einfach wieder zusammen freiheiten in
die tasche stecken sich irgendwo
dranhängen das machen heute schon so
viele das ist so einfach
nein man kann den zusammenfalten und
youtube mit dem auf den kopf gesetzt
vielen dank frau schulze ganz toll ja
auch in dieser woche haben wieder
mehrere groko politiker im bundestag
gesagt wir stehen zu den klimazielen die
wir verfehlen
ich sage jetzt mal was sehr unpopulär
ist meine damen und herren bei uns in
deutschland wird seit jahren in die
völlig falsche richtung geforscht
wissen sie wer wirklich schuld ist an
der ganzen erderwärmung nicht autos oder
kohlekraftwerke nein schuld daran dass
es bei uns immer wärmer wird sind die
dänen ständig kalt ist ja wem ist denn
ständig kalt irgendwie kalt ganz genau
frauen sind schuld ja natürlich wer denn
sonst frauen
sie sahen eine information der penis
träger gegen die überhitzung des
abendlandes kurz
grau
das problem darüber sollten die
mainstream medien berichten lügen presse
jetzt aber jetzt aber zur eigentlichen
sensation der woche die erste große
partei die ein klima konzept vorgelegt
hat ist ausgerechnet die csu ja
ausgerechnet söder der alte grünen
fresser ist es doch wahnsinn wirklich
gut auch in dem papier stehen jetzt noch
keine regelrechten wie heißt das noch
womit man sich immer so doof festlegt
zahlen genau also was bayern bereit wäre
wirklich für klimaschutz zu blechen
steht nicht drin aber als geste ist das
ganze schon ein kulturschock
wie geht die parteibasis damit um
bescheiden mal live zum csu ortsverband
wieder unter hinterhof geleitet von
matthias matschke
wie gefällt ihnen denn ihre neue r
grünte csu 1 a bird dog days oder hat
doch völlig recht es muss ja was
passieren die uhr tickt und jede von uns
kann seinen beitrag leisten mülltrennung
mitzufahren ernährung ist ja wasser
sommer mal mit sehen wir haben doch
keine hudson bestellt frei dass es mir
von der csu seien nur noch salat welchen
dem klima und so und da so ein
glutenfreies ging die scheiße der
schmeckt der wie toni hofreiter unterm
arm
aber egal mir zehn ingo quatsch jetzt
durch weil er funktioniert es plötzlich
deutschlands beliebteste politiker
markus söder beliebt das sind drei worte
die dürften überhaupt nicht im selben
satz vorkommen manchen behaupten der
wird kanzlerkandidat ruhig baby das ist
ja nur eine theorie also manches in dem
csu konzept finde ich gut da steht zum
beispiel kohle ausstiegs schon 2030 ja
stimmt das kann er vorschlagen vor allem
wenn man in bayern kann gramkow ladner
ja solche ideen kost nix und erhöhen die
aussies zwei fliegen mit einer klappe
nach der marcos macht es schon super
jeder spruch wie aus dem kalenderblatt
ausgeschnitten lassen sich den einmal
sacken nicht nur verbieten fleisch essen
oder frieden sondern intelligente andere
als system haben damit bürger entlastet
werden
wir wollen diesen gedanken laptop und
lederhose neu übersetzen der russe steht
eigentlich für die natur der lederhose
steht für die natur
das klingt wenn softporno aus 170 jahren
unter dem bild steht in lederhose und
verlachen keine dass in bayern jeden tag
11,7 hektar fläche versiegelt wird für
noch mehr gewerbegebiete die grüne csu
großartig
also ändert sich doch eher wenig im
freistaat doch also hier in bayern
werden schon ab sachen angezogen
die wohl dem klimaschutz enorm helfen
die tierschutzorganisation peta fordert
nämlich dass jesus künftig bei den
passionsspielen nicht mehr auf einem
esel nach jerusalem einzieht sondern
einen e-scooter darin nimmt unsere
proben laufen schon hier kommt der esi
ass
[Musik]
planet gerettet
matthias matschke meine damen und herren
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal